just when it looked like things were
moving in the right direction a second
protest started causing issues on
highway 4 in southern alberta
protesters actually arrived at this spot
on tuesday in a show of support for the
demonstrations in koots but it wasn't
until wednesday night that they actually
started blocking the highway and it
appears to be a rotating blockade
however limited traffic is able to get
through including transport vehicles
headed to the border police are asking
that the public stay away from the area
and rcmp actually have their own
blockade up to ensure that only people
who live in the area or need to get to
the border for work reasons are allowed
through now this all comes after some
big moves on wednesday after
negotiations with rcmp protesters
blocking the highway to the coots border
opened up a lane in each direction but
ones we spoke with warned the protest is
far from over and their message and goal
is still clear to end all mandates
that's what happens we're going to stay
where we are if not we're gonna block
off the highways again i just want
everyone to understand that we're
fighting out here fighting for our
freedom and get rid of the mandates in
the vaccine
and while a lot has been changing here
in the last few days rcmp do say there
have been no arrests and no reports of
violence lauren pullen global news